shadow climate change uh secretary ed
miliband is with us he's got a point
hasn't i mean why would he not go and
meet with the raf if we're if there's
war in europe
i mean the guy's checked out isn't he i
mean he's sort of
you know he's an assault i think
i mean the idea
you know we've had these cobra emergency
meetings about the heat wave the idea
that any previous prime minister and i
include tory conservative prime
ministers in this
would at a time of potential national
emergency be just absent i mean it just
seems absolutely bizarre but the cobra
meeting reports to cabinet is what we're
being told by the transformers this
morning i mean look i i was close to
gordon brown when i was in government i
remember we had all kinds of just when
he took over we had floods we had you
know gordon was right there
you know the the authority of the prime
minister matters in these things i mean
looking away he's on his way out so but
he's sort of carried on it's the kind of
cavalier approach we've seen while he's
been prime minister i would have thought
that labour would be pleased that he
wasn't getting involved
keep him out the way i think there's
some i think you know whoever the prime
minister is there's something about
having the authority of the prime
minister to take this seriously as an
issue but look you know it is what it is
he's gone so he's going yeah um
record temperatures yeah expected um
today um this could be the new normal is
what we're being told why aren't
labour putting more pressure on the
government
well that's why i'm here um
look it's very serious the new normal is
exactly the right way to describe it i
just it's just worth saying to your
viewers the planet is hotter than it's
been for 125 000 years
um we've got one degree of warming so
far but i don't want to be a doom monger
but you know
we're going to get more than one degree
of warming that's the average and that
will mean more extreme heat potentially
higher than 39 40 degrees that we're
seeing and we are not ready as a country
we are not ready on this at all not by a
long shot our infrastructure isn't ready
in fact we don't even know whether our
infrastructure is resilient there's you
believe it or not okay the process of
testing whether our infrastructure is
resilient is voluntary at the moment
it's not mandatory we don't have
workplace maximum workplace temperatures
that other countries have to keep
workers safe and 20 of existing homes at
risk of overheating and the government's
doing nothing about it and the committee
that looks at these things which i set
up when i was in government has said the
government just ignored repeated
warnings from them so we've got to get
serious about resilience the met office
just telling us that it does look as
though it was the hottest temperature
ever overnight uh last night um so um as
night follows day let's let's find out
what happens later on today but jeremy
corbyn pledged to meet net zero by 2030.
zakir star was sort of rode back on that
well in the manifesto jeremy corbyn said
we'd have the substantial majority of
our emissions taken away reduced by 2030
and that's still our position and we've
made a big commitment labor under
kierstarma which is to invest 28 billion
pounds a year in the green energy we
need in the energy efficiency we need
and i think this energy efficiency is
really interesting we've got 90 million
cold drafty homes at least that's how i
normally talk about them
that that could do with energy
efficiency we want to help householders
do that they're not just cold and drafty
they're at risk of overheating as well
and we've got to tackle both ends of
this and i'm afraid when you look at the
tory leadership election kay and i'm
sorry they're not going to be debating
with you uh tonight they're running
they're running scared they're running
scared of k burley but but you know um
you know what you've seen over them
you've got extreme heat wave we know the
climate challenge we had cop 26 last
year what are they doing they're not
running towards net zero they're running
away from it i mean what an unserious
party that is running away from a
climate commitment you know david
cameron was my opponent for five years
but to be fair to him he did convert the
conservative party push the conservative
party to adopt the green agenda and now
we've got candidates at when we know
much more about it running away from it
it's shameful frankly so you would keep
the green levy even though families are
struggling to cope well what i would not
do
is say we're going to abolish the green
levees without a replacement there's a
legitimate debate about whether it can
be funded from public expenditure or
taxation but if you're going to say that
you've got to say where the money's
coming from and these tory candidates
are not doing that and if you want to
know why have energy bills gone up it's
not the green levees okay the green
levels are 150 quid that's important but
they're at pretty stable levels it's
actually that fossil fuel prices have
gone up and what should we be doing in
relation to that we should be driving
helpful leather for solar power onshore
wind offshore wind all of the renewable
energy nuclear power and we're not doing
that and yesterday to top it all off the
high court find the gut found the
government's net zero strategy unlawful
because it's so useless and look that is
where we are even if you took power yeah
in 2024 you'd still only have six years
to try to reach your 2030. and it will
be an absolute sprint every part of
government you know and actually this is
the reason i'm still in politics okay
i'm still in politics because of this
issue you know frontline politics there
are many harder jobs but frontline
politics as you know because we've known
each other over the years has a lot of
challenges but i'm still at this because
you know attenborough says david
attenborough says the next few years
will determine the next few thousand
years
you know there can be no more important
issue to i feel privileged to be in
charge of this issue for labour and i'm
desperate to get into government to
tackle it alex sharma threatened to quit
uh as president of cop 26 if any of the
tory leadership candidates dropped yeah
and i congratulated him by text i'll let
you into a secret because it's really
good that he did that but what will
happen to our presidency if he does do
that what does that say to the rest of
the world well it's terrible but i mean
you've got a party that has the
conservative party that's lost touch
with reality i mean what is this
leadership contest it is it's depressing
frankly live my opponents but it's
depressing because one of the things
we've prided ourselves on this country
in this country not like america is okay
we've got a consensus about how we
tackle climate change all the speed but
we've got a consensus about tackling it
and you've got these candidates all
wanting to sort of you know compete with
each other to say well i'm not you know
i'm i'm suspicious about this i'm
suspicious about that that is the wrong
way to go we should be all in on
tackling this climate emergency for now
for the future to tackle the cost of
living crisis and to create good jobs
obviously looked at what they've all
been saying about it i mean two years
before you guys get an opportunity to
potentially run the country who at the
moment of the remaining four do you
think would do the best job at trying to
save the planet
i mean honestly i think they're all
really
maybe
well i don't i don't really have it i
mean look soon said that he wants to
well let me go through them you've got
kami badanok she says that tackling that
zero is unilateral economic disarmament
well that's nonsense just change the
tune on that well okay great but i mean
that's right you've gotta take you know
first answer you know what i mean you
gotta see what she said first of all
rishi sunak has dragged his feet in the
treasury on investing in the green uh in
the green agenda energy efficiency
you've got other people in government
deeply frustrated with him um who else
have you got left you've got liz trust
she says fracking is the answer and
penny morgan who says that green levees
are the main problem you know this is
illiteracy this is climate illiteracy
from this party and and honestly i don't
say that just because they're my
opponents i wouldn't have said that
about david cameron now he said cut the
green sea word but you know
at least at the beginning he was he was
interested in in dealing with this it's
bad what is going on and it's bad for
the country okay it's good to see you as
always thanks so much for joining us